This video is made possible by brilliant.
You're going to learn more about brilliant later in today's video,
but if you'd like to learn more about them right now,
got a brilliant at org forward.
Slash.
Biographics.
You'll also find a link in the description below.
Leon Trotsky was a man of thought and action.
His dream of a Utopian society built on Marxism.
It crumbles around him,
yet he never gave up on his ideals when he was sidelines by the power hungry
Joseph Stalin,
he wielded his pen to expose the desk spot to the world knowing full well that
didn't doing so he was signing his own death warrants.
In today's biographics,
we discover the man who was Leon Trotsky.
Okay.
The man who is known to history as Leon Trotsky was born at Lev Davidovich
Bronstein on November the seventh 1879 his parents,
David and Anna were farmers in the Ukrainian village of young covert.
David has built himself up from nothing to become one of the most successful
farmers in the entire region.
Lev was the fifth child born to the bronze deans during his first eight years.
He was kept on the farm and instructed by his parents.
The language they spoke was a mixture of Russian and Ukrainian.
Then at the age of eight,
he was sent to a private Ukrainian Jewish school in Adesa and Ukraine.
Let's struggled during his first year at school is he was not familiar with the
vernacular riff Jewish Yiddish that were spoken in time.
Though he improved and he proved himself to be a very capable students.
You quickly learn to speak Russian and he fell in love with Russian literature.
After two years at the private school,
Lev was transferred to a state run Russian school.
As in Paul's High School,
he excelled to beat one of the top students.
However,
he proved to be an independent thinker,
which sometimes led to run ins with his teachers.
His reading of such intellectual giants like Leo Tolstoy gave him the knowledge
to challenge things that the other students except it about the order of society
which caused frustration for his long suffering.
Instructors graduating from school at the age of 17 left moved to the Ukrainian
port town of Nikolai of close to the black seat.
He lived with two relatives while he decided what he wanted to do with his life.
Nikolai of at that time was a sensor of revolutionary descends and the teenagers
lab as soon began to mingle with the radical crowd
within a few months of arriving in Nikolayev Love Matt,
a young woman by the name of Alexandria Sokolov Skype.
She was six years older than Levins,
well versed and revolutionary leftist politics.
Lovely to record that he was attracted to Alexandra because she was the only
person who was able to defeat him in a debate.
The subject is history.
It was Marxism and whether it would be the best thing for Russian society.
They've argued against it,
but every arguments that he made was definitely destroyed by the wit and the
wisdom of Alexandra Levy found himself falling in love with her,
but hardly before the relationship could get established.
He was thrown in jail.
The course of his imprisonments in January of 1898 was this involvement in a
demonstration of striking members over the next two years.
He was a regularly thrown in jail for short spells as a result of his
involvement in public demonstrations in 1,911 Alexandra,
they were married shortly after the wedding.
Alexandra was banished to Simon area for four years as a result of our own
radical activities.
And your husband though he went right along with that.
They ended up in these Siberian village of [inaudible] over the next two years.
They eat out are living in this cold and harsh terrain.
The couple of ones who had two children,
girls named.
So Neda and Nina.
After two years of this exile,
live fat already had enough and he was ready to make his escape by now.
His wife had fully converted him to Marxism,
communism and he was determined to get out of this purgatory and it's become
active in the revolutionary cause.
It was a result of that.
Alexandra would remain in so area with the two young children.
Let's travel to the [inaudible] region of Siberia.
There.
He got a hold of a stolen passport.
It was then that he assumed his new name scribbling.
It's on the pages of the fake passports.
Leon Trotsky.
He made his way to London and you get to learn at the feet of the founder of
Russian Marxism,
Vladimir Lenin.
The two men developed an immediate bonds.
Lenin Trotsky on as his apprentice setting him to work as a writer for his
Communist newspaper is scrap within a couple of months of his arrival.
Then in sent him out on a fundraising and publicity tour of Europe.
Do you promote the newspaper as well as the communist cause all the Paris leg of
the tour,
he met a young woman by the name of Natalia Sedova.
Despite still being married to Alexandra at PN,
Natalia soon became mounted wife.
She returned with him to London and they sat up.
How's that?
Not long after his return from Europe,
Trotsky attended the second congress of the Democratic Workers Party in London.
The main topic of discussion was the recent splits in the Russian Communist
Party between the Mensheviks and the Bolsheviks,
the Mensheviks.
Well,
the more moderate of the two factions who envisions a gradual transition to
communism,
the Bolsheviks,
however,
they were far more radical.
They intend to do this man's or the current system immediately and replace it
with full on communism.
They were fully prepared to stage violence uprising in order to achieve that
means the names of these factions.
They tell us about their levels of support.
The Menshevik means man of the minority.
You're,
while Bolsheviks translates to men of the majority,
nothing was in favor of the Bolsheviks or the camera is amazing.
He explained the Bolsheviks needed to create a centralized power structure from
which they could control and direct the common people.
This idea,
it was very troubling to Trotsky who saw it as a replacement of the type of
capitalist control of the masses that they were trying to get rid of for many
years after that.
As he continued to try and bridge the divide between the Bolsheviks and the
Mensheviks
in 1905 Russia at suffered a humiliating defeat against the Japanese in the
battle of true Shima.
They'd left the Russian economy in ruins and has led to mass demonstrations on
January the 22nd 1905 the peaceful demonstration gathered outside of San Nicolas
is winter palace.
Nicholas reacted sending in the cavalry.
The demonstrators were routed with hundreds being killed in the street.
The people,
they were outraged and the Bolshevik ranks.
However,
celebrations began to occur.
They saw this as the spark that would bring on the great communist revolution
over the following months.
Protest screwed larger,
morphing into the general strike of October,
1905 over that period of time,
the Bolsheviks,
they were busy organizing the resistance.
Both of Lenin and Trotsky had relocated to some peaches back.
Trotsky began organizing special work as assemblies.
These groups were designed to take control of regions that were to be governed
by a workers council.
The Russian word for council will that'd be Soviets.
Trotsky set up the first Soviet and some Peter's bag with him serving as its
chairman in short order.
The region was surrounded by the Siris Armenians.
Trotsky was taken into captivity.
He was held in prison for nearly a year before being put on trial.
Defending the charge of leading the armed rebellion.
Trotsky gave an impressive speech in which he laid out all the benefits of
Marxism.
All of this was in vain.
However,
as he was convicted and he was exiled once again to Siberia,
Trump's get determined that there was no way that he was going back to that
Siberian wilderness.
In January of 1907 he escaped while being transported to his place of
banishments for a second time.
He headed off to London.
Within weeks,
though,
he had relocated to Vienna in Austria.
It was there that he started working for the communist propaganda newspaper.
Pravda financing.
The ongoing publication of Pravda was a constant challenge.
In 1909 Trotsky requested that the Bolshevik central committee inject funds to
keep the paper going.
Lennon now with the head of the Bolsheviks agreed,
but only on the condition that a Bolshevik be put in place as assistant editor.
There's men's that the moderate views which Trotsky had managed to infuse into
the paper,
we're no longer going to be acceptable.
From 1910 onwards,
provder became the mouthpiece of Bolshevik communism.
Tensions between the Bolsheviks and the Mensheviks.
They continued to cause division.
In 1912 Lennon instigated a purge to remove the moderate voices.
Trotsky remains in opposition to the more radical actions of the Bolsheviks such
as armed robberies of banks to finance the party.
He organized a unification conference to bring the factions together,
but it was a failure.
Yeah,
is around 1912 Trotsky wrote for a number of radical Russian and Ukrainian
newspapers.
In September of that year,
he was sent on assignment to cover the Balkan war.
When World War One breakouts,
he moved from Australia to Switzerland and then to Paris.
From his base there,
he wrote antiwar diatribes in which witchy describes the injustice of the
workers of the world who were being forced to kill each other at the beckoning
of their rulers,
the French government.
They were not impressed with this anti war stance since they're Trotsky
deported.
On March 31st,
1916 Trotsky,
he went to Spain.
Bird says writing said to deportation from that country as well.
He ultimately ended up in the United States.
They arrived in New York on January the 13th 1917 he says,
old into a small room and the Bronx and began writing for several Russian
newspapers.
And month after his arrival in the u s Trotsky received the news that saw
Nicholas had been overthrown.
He designed it to return in order to do play his part in the history that was
unfolding.
On march the 27th of 1917 Trotsky sailed from New York harbor on bold,
the s s Christiana fought.
However,
the ship was intercepted by the British Navy at Halifax,
Nova Scotia,
and Trotsky.
It was held in an internment camp for a month through the intervention of the
Russian foreign minister.
He was released and he was able to continue on to Russia.
Now just before we get into the very important October Revolution,
I do want to tell you a bit about brilliant,
brilliant,
uh,
signs of lending platform that allow you to learn through active learning.
Basically some dump.
This is the opposite of that feeling where you read a really complex paragraph
about some principle and then you've just got no clue what on earth is going on.
Even if you've read it through 10 times,
you still like,
Huh,
anyway,
and brilliant.
Don't just teach you the basics,
so they do cover that as well.
They go all the way to complex things like differential equations,
but you've heard me talk a bunch of our brilliant previously.
If you're a regular viewer,
I think that a perfect fit for this channel because hey,
you're probably ends are learning and education because you're on youtube and
you watching as a 20 minute educational video,
so you're into learning.
You're into this channel.
You'll probably be into brilliant too recently.
Brilliant.
Made an important update to their mobile apps so that now causes can be accessed
offline so you didn't have to worry about having a solid internet connections.
You learn things through that platform.
Maybe this means you can spend your commute learning something or indeed you can
learn something wherever you want.
Brilliant.
Makes even complex concepts.
Easy to understand is they give you something super short to read,
it's really easy,
and then you immediately apply it to a problem or rinse and repeat and suddenly
you're understanding all sorts of stuff that you didn't think you'd ever get.
Full courses are totally interactive,
so you can learn probability by playing blackjack or you can learn the physics
of motion using interactive models of pendulum clocks.
So if you want to support biographics,
which would be awesome and get unlimited access to all of brilliance in depth
math and science courses,
you can head over to brilliant.org forward slash biographics and get 20% off the
annual premium subscription.
And let's get back to Trotsky and his revolution.
Following the ousting of San Nicolas,
it's supposedly neutral provisional government was put into place until a more
permanent government could be established.
Trotsky arrived in St Petersburg on May the 17th 1917 he soon became a popular
speaker at town halls and factories as the various political elements vying for
power.
His catch phrase embodied the three tenants of his revolution,
revision,
distrust the bourgeoisie,
control our own leaders,
and to have confidence in our revolutionary forces.
The Bolsheviks,
they struggled for more radical changes than the state government or doom or
envisions.
Trotsky aligned himself with the Bolsheviks.
He was arrested on August the seventh for his involvement in a Bolshevik
demonstration.
They spent 40 days in prison is probably used to that at this point.
On October the eighth with the Bolsheviks support gaining ascendancy,
Trotsky was voted governor of the Sun Petersburg Soviets for a second time.
By the end of the year,
the provisional government's,
it had failed.
It was superseded by the Bolsheviks with Lennon of that hat.
The second most powerful man,
all that was Leon Trotsky
and immediate focus for the Bolshevik government was to get Russia out of the
war.
This task was handed to Trotsky along with the title of People's Commissar for
foreign affairs.
On December the second 1917 the Bolsheviks signed to cease fire with the allied
central powers,
Germany,
Austria,
Hungary,
and tocky talks then began between Trotsky and the central power delegates to
work out and armistice agreement.
The Germans in particular,
they drove a hard bargain.
They demanded that the Russians give up their claim to Ukraine,
Poland,
Lithuania as well as parts of Latvia and Bella Russia.
Trotsky was taken aback by the demands,
but he also knew that he had little choice.
The Bolsheviks had campaigns on a platform of getting Russia out of the war and
all of Russia was essentially demanding vast Trotsky.
He related the demands to Len and adding this.
He felt they had no choice but to agree that he was at the same opinion,
but when the rest of the Bolshevik governments had the demands,
they were infuriated.
They managed to convince both Trotsky and Lenin not to sign the armistice.
In the end is Trotsky simply decided to pull out of the hostilities without the
benefit of anonymous disagreements.
He explains,
we declare we ends the war,
but will not sign a piece.
They will be unable to make an offensive against us if they attack us.
All position will be no worse than now.
It was a gamble that Trotsky would immediately regret it.
On February the 18th or 19th 18 Austrian and German forces,
they invaded Russia.
They found the borders compete be on defendant.
On hearing the news,
Trotsky,
he was dumbfounded.
He sent a message to the German ambassador stating,
we request clarification of this misunderstanding,
but there was no misunderstanding.
The very next day,
Trotsky was commanded by Lenin to,
except of the original German conditions for the armistice.
Yeah.
Okay.
With Russia now,
out of the wall,
Trotsky was made commander in chief of the armed forces.
A crisis occurred when the Czech Slovak legions returning from the war revolted
against the Bolshevik governments.
The resistance grew into what became known as the White Army.
When he heard that the outpost of Cazan had fallen to this opposition,
Trotsky hopped on a train and headed for the area to assess the situation for
himself.
Has trained only made it part of the way before he was forced to turn back,
but before they could get out of town,
the white army forces that surrounded Trotsky's contingent for 25 days.
They were forced to fend off the assault until they were finally able to break
out and returned to some peaches bag with the white army,
challenging them from the east.
The Bolsheviks also faced pressure from the north.
There's a finished group known as the white guard sought to rescued,
saw Nicholas and his family from captivity.
The group,
we're on the verge of control of the town of Yak Taryn bag,
which is where they're all family were being held captive.
Then the order came through to kill the entire royal family with this terrible
deed done.
The Bolsheviks were ousted from the town.
However,
the white guards,
they were simply too late to save Nicholas or his family.
At the beginning of 1919 Russia,
it was in a state of crisis.
Civil wars.
It racked to the country hands now disease,
famine,
and poverty decimated the population.
Meanwhile,
European powers hovered around like vultures ready to devour the Russian corpse.
By October,
the white army has almost total control into a pressing at the gates of some
peaches bag.
The Soviet government ordered a full scale retreat from the capitol.
This Trotsky,
he strongly disagreed.
He rallied his supporters to resist to the very last man Trotsky's bravery,
persistence,
and strong personality turns the tide.
The Soviet forces dug in and managed to push back the why Tommy,
some Petersburg was safe and it's the tide of the civil war.
It began to change in favor of the Bolsheviks.
By the end of 1920 the white Tommy had been concentrated in Siberia.
The Soviets had survived.
You see off their enemies and cement that leadership.
However,
in May of 1922 that leader and visionary Vladimir Lenin,
he had a massive stroke.
Trotsky would have seemed to have been the natural successor.
However,
there was another member of the Bolshevik power structure who had other ideas
and his name,
of course,
with Joseph Stalin.
Joseph Stalin was a street fighter and a thug.
It would cajoled is Wayne's becoming the general secretary of the Soviet Union.
By the time that Lennon died,
the position it didn't hold any real power with all of his actions being
controlled by the executive committee or the PELLISSIPPI row.
By the end of 1922 Lennon had recovered sufficiently to send a note to the
political bureau giving us thoughts on his successor.
He stated the Trotsky was a stronger personality than stolen bus,
that he was too prone to acting unilaterally without consulting the rest of the
council.
As for Stalin,
he considered him to be too rude,
too ruthless,
and to intolerance.
Lenin held on until January the 21st 1924 during that time,
it became clear to style and that the dying leader favored Trotsky over him.
This is him to embark on a ruthless campaign to discredit Trotsky.
He claimed that Trotsky was trying to cause divisions within the party by trying
to push down to the old guards in favor of younger members who were more
inclined to its will stolen.
Managed to have a book that Trotsky had written in 1923 bands from sale as being
anti Leninist,
even though it was nothing of the sort.
The open and constant criticisms of Trotsky resulted in the loss of his do
officers is chairman of the war council and People's Commissar of war and navy.
After spending almost all of 1925 without a job,
Trotsky was recorded in 1926 and given three roles.
However,
it stolen interfered so much that he resigned from two of them only retaining
the position of chairman of the concessions committee,
but Stalin was not through with Trotsky yet.
I'll,
November the 12th 1927 he had been expelled from the Communist Party and then
Exxon to Kazakhstan.
Three months later,
he was completely bands from living in the Soviet Union,
Soviet gods.
They forced him onto a train and would not tell him where he was going.
After going on a hunger strike,
he was finally informed that he was headed for Turkey.
This enraged Trotsky who is convinced that the anticommunist regime there,
which have him executed immediately,
he sends a message to the central committee requesting a change of heart,
but there was no response.
There's surprisingly the tax.
They treated Trotsky with the greatest respect he was given a home to live in
with his wife and his Holly errands.
There's some lev from his new base.
He began writing about the situation within the Soviet Union and specifically
the failings of Stalin.
He didn't hold back riding the following in an article titled,
What is stolen is political.
Horizon is extremely narrow.
He has the mentality of a dog and empiricist devoid of creative imagination.
These writings were published in newspapers around the world knowing what we do
now about Stalin's personality.
It is a wonder that he didn't have Trotsky killed immediately,
but to have done so would have been to bring the condemnation of the world down
on stolen.
As a result,
he sought to shut him up by sending him deeper into exile.
The tax received orders to remove Trotsky to the island of PrinCap buyer.
After a year there,
he managed to get political asylum in France.
The French would not allow Trotsky to live in Paris,
so he settled in the coastal community of Rome.
He spends almost two years that,
but then French Soviet relations improved and the government was pressured to
deport him for a year.
He stayed in Norway with journalist Conrad can loosen.
While that he wrote the revolution betrayed,
which further highlighted the failings of Joseph Stalin a furious and pressured
the Norwegian governments and Trotsky was once again deported.
He and his wife and son,
they now had did for Trotsky's final destination of Mexico for just over two
years.
From January,
1937 to April of 1939 they lived with artists,
Diego Riviera Rent Frida Kahlo.
During that time,
and Trotsky had an affair with Freider even though his wife and son were also
living under the same roof.
In April of 1939 the Trotsky's moved into their own home a few streets away from
Diego and Frieda.
It was here that he wrote his strongest attack on stolen.
Yet.
The article was titled Hitler and Stalin in it's,
he wrote about Stalin's hypocrisy and signing a nonaggression pact with Hitler.
It stages over the last three years,
Starlin is labeled every one of Lennon's comrades in arms agents of Hitler
having destroyed the army posse and decapitated the army stolen and is now
openly advancing his candidature as hipness chief agents.
Bye now.
Trotsky was convinced that Stalin would soon to silence him.
On February the 27th of 1940 he wrote Trotsky's testaments in which he defended
himself as a loyal party member.
In the mid 1940s Trotsky's house was swarmed by members of the Russian secret
police,
the and KVD Trotsky's.
God's managed to fight them off.
They following the failed assassination attempt to Trotsky wrote an article
titled at Stalin's seeks my death on June the eighth 1940 in which he stated
that another assassination was absolutely certain.
A month later on August the 20th of 1940 a man walked into Trotsky study and
buried in ice pick into his head drops.
Ski Did not die immediately.
They rather p fought the attacker until his body guards were able to come in and
subdue him.
Trotsky was rushed to the local hospital.
According to James Buchanan,
the secretary of the Socialist Workers Party in the USA.
Trotsky's last words were,
I will not survive this attack.
Starlin has finally accomplished the task he attempted on successfully before he
died the next day.
So I already have you found that video.
Interesting.
If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below and don't forget to subscribe.
We've got brand new videos just like this several days a week.
So hit that subscribe button to find out about those.
If you're looking for something else from me,
I've got another channel called top tens.
You will find that link to below,
and as always,
thank you for watching.